Hey guys, today I'm going to show you
how to create and design this super
awesome premium animated carousel inside
Figma. There's no plugins, no fancy
tools needed. A while ago, we posted a
short of this carousel in action, and
you guys loved it. So, the comments from
you were absolutely amazing. So, we
decided to create a full step-by-step
tutorial so that you can learn how to
build something similar yourself. Now,
the best part is it's really easy to
follow, even if you're a complete
beginner. We'll go step by step from a
blank canvas all the way to a smooth
working prototype. You'll learn how to
design it, animate it, and make it look
clean and fun to use. And if you want
access to the source file of this entire
design along with extra bonus tutorial
and extra tips, it's all available for
our Patreon members. The link's in the
description if you want to check that
out. And hey, I'd seriously love to see
what you create with this. So, if you
post your version anywhere on social
media, just tag us so that we can check
it out and share some love. All right, I
am super excited. So, let's not waste
any more time and let's get into it. All
right, before we jump into the actual
design, we're going to prep everything.
Our typography, colors, icons, and
images. It might feel like a small step,
but this will actually make the whole
process way faster and smoother. We'll
be using two fonts for this project.
Oswald and Inter. Both are Google fonts.
So if you don't have them, you can just
download them for free.
Now, we aim to have a bold yet luxurious
feel. So for the headings, we'll be
using a font called Oswald in all caps.
We're going to follow a simple naming
style for all our text like heading XL,
heading LG, and heading medium just to
keep things clean and consistent. So the
first one is heading XL font size 148
pixels and weight semibold.
Next heading LG. We'll set this to 70
pixels also semibold.
And here's heading medium. Same Oswald
font, but this time the weight is
medium, size 24 pixels. And we'll
increase the letter spacing to 4%.
Cool. All right, those are our heading
styles. Now on to the body text. Now
here we're switching to enter and we'll
keep the letter case as type.
So letter spacing is 0%.
We'll call this style body XL regular.
Font size is 28 pixels
and line height 160%.
font weight semi- bold.
[Music]
Actually, since we're using semi-bold
weight here, let's rename that to body
XL semi bold just to keep the naming
consistent.
Now, let's finish setting up the rest of
our body textiles. Starting with body
LG, we'll make one with regular weight
at 20 pixels.
Then we'll create a second version of
Body LG, but this time with medium
weight.
And next is body MD.
But first, we'll set one with regular
weight and a smaller size with a font
size of 18 pixels.
Then we'll duplicate that and create a
semi-bold version. And let's also add a
medium weight version just to keep it
flexible.
Lastly, we've got body SM. Font size 16
pixels with both regular and semi-bold
weights.
Awesome.
All right, we have the typography now.
All done. Everything styled, named, and
ready to roll.
Now, let's add some flavor. It's color
time. So, let's set up our color
palette. I'm going to create a circle
for each color that we'll be using.
[Music]
Starting with our darkest primary color.
Now, this will be used for the
background to give everything that
luxury high-end feel. So, next I'm going
to add a neutral gray. We'll use this
for borders and outlines on some of the
UI elements.
All right. Now, for a light gray, which
we'll mostly use for the copy and small
labels.
All right. Now, let's add in our bold
red. This is going to be the main color
for for our buttons, excuse me.
And I'll also add two creamy colors. One
of them will be used for button
backgrounds and the other one for
headings.
Cool. All right. Now, let's move on to
our complimentary colors. Now, first a
light green. We're going to use this to
highlight a few feature sections.
Then a light red again mainly for
accents or uh decorative elements.
Next is a pastel yellow
and then a slightly softer yellow just
to give us uh some flexibility in tones.
Adding a light pink here as well.
And let's do one more. A nice soft light
orange to round out the palette.
Perfect. Awesome. All right. Cool. So,
we got our colors in place and ready to
use. Let's move on to images.
I'm going to add in a floating hamburger
image here. This is the one we're going
to animate later. All right, just so you
know, you can find similar images on
Freepick or Invato. just search for
floating burger or burger layers. But if
you want to use the exact same image
here that I'm using, so there's a free
download in the description, just scroll
down and grab it.
Now I'll drop the layered hamburger in
the frame.
As you can see, this image has all the
layers separated. the bun, meat,
lettuce, tomato, everything is in its
own layer. Now, that's going to be
really important for the animation
later. So, make sure your burger is
layered, too. If you're using an image
that is not layered, we've included a
bonus Photoshop tutorial for our Patreon
members showing you exactly how to
separate layers easily. Plus, you'll get
this full project file and a detailed
tutorial on how we generated this kind
of image using chat GPT prompts. Now, if
you haven't grabbed your image yet, feel
free to pause here and either find one
online or download the one from the
link. All right,
cool. So, now that we've got our images
in place, the last thing to prep is our
icons.
Now, for this project, we are grabbing
all of our icons from Phosphor Icons. It
is a great free site where you can
customize the style, size, and color. So
let's start with the first one. We'll
search for fire.
We are choosing the filled style,
setting the size to 24 pixels,
and clicking copy to clipboard.
Then we'll head over to Figma and paste
it right in.
Now we'll repeat this same process for
each icon we need in the design.
[Music]
And here's the last one grain. Same
deal. Copy and drop it into the frame.
And that is it. Our typography, our
colors, our images, and icons are all
ready to go. The next move is a pro tip
that is actually going to save you
hours. Trust me on that. So, we're
setting up text styles and color styles
so that you can update your designs in
seconds, not hours. So, watch this.
I'm selecting our first heading. Now,
over in the text panel, click on the
style icon, these four little dots here.
Then, hit the plus button. Name it
heading XL or whatever you want to call
it, and click create style. Boom. That's
now a reusable text style, and it shows
up in the design panel, too. Now, we'll
do this for every text style that we've
created. Heading LG, body, XL, you get
the idea.
[Music]
and here's why this matters. So, say you
decide to change your font later. If you
set this up right, you can only change
it once. And Figma updates every single
instance in your design. So there's no
more clicking through every screen. It's
fast. It's clean. And honestly, it's
it's how real designers work. And last
one here. And then we are done with
textiles.
All right. Now, let's do the exact same
thing for our colors.
Select each color, click on the style
icon, hit plus, and name them whatever
works for you, like primary, secondary,
or something more specific.
And done.
[Music]
Having
these color styles uh set up will
actually make things faster later on.
And I promise it'll save you more than
once.
and done. So, we've got them all saved
as color styles. Now you'll see them all
nicely listed in the right panel. Clean
and organized. Looks super professional.
And all right, we can finally start
designing our first screen. Now I'm
hitting the frame tool and selecting the
MacBook 16in preset.
Now, you don't have to do this part, but
I'm changing the height to 992 pixels.
just so everything fits nicely on my
screen when I present later. All right,
let's set the mood. I'm applying our
pure black from the color styles as the
background. Now, I'll hit T for text and
type out our main heading, Crown Burger.
So, for this, I'm using our larger text
style heading XL and aligning it to the
center of the frame. So, let's give it
some contrast. I'm applying our light
cream as the text color.
And now, just above that, I'm adding a
smaller heading, this week's favorite.
Now, this one uses the heading medium
style with a light gray color.
And below our main heading, I'm dropping
in a quick value prop.
A premium burger that delivers all the
flavor you crave.
Made with healthier ingredients you can
trust.
Cool. Sounds good. Clean and clear. It's
what we're going for.
And now I'm going to select all three
text layers and apply an auto layout
using shift + a.
So let's set a 12 pixel gap between the
main heading and the paragraph.
And that is it. Cool. The hero section
is is starting to take shape. So now
let's build out the navigation for our
website.
For the menu items, I'm using our body
medium textile with a medium weight
[Music]
and applying our light gray as the text
color. And the first nav item is order.
Then find restaurant
offers
menu
delivery
and more.
I'll select the last three items and
apply auto layout and then set the
spacing to 54 pixels.
I'll do the same for the first three on
the left.
Now, let's make space in the middle for
our logo.
I'm going to create um something a bit
custom here. So, I'll type out BKG using
odd oswald, excuse me.
and set the size to 18 pixels.
Then what I'll do is I'll draw a
horizontal line with round edges.
rounded edges just like that. Yep.
And letter spacing to zero. Font weight
to semi-bold.
Now I'll bring in the fire icon we
downloaded earlier and give it our bold
red color to just spice it up.
Cool. I'll wrap the whole logo in an
auto layout and add some padding.
Heat. Hey, Heat.
and set the corner radius to 16 pixels.
Let me just tweak that spacing a bit.
All
right, cool.
Yeah, that looks nice. Cool. I'll align
it with the menu items and apply auto
layout to the full nav row.
To make sure the logo stays perfectly
centered, we need to match the width to
the sorry, we need to match the width of
the left and right menu sections. And
once that's balanced, we can center line
everything nice and cleanly.
Now, let's build our buttons. One for
signup and one for the shopping cart.
For both, I'm using a semi-bold font,
wrapping them in auto layout, and
setting the padding to 24 pixels
horizontally and 12 pixels vertically.
The first button gets a primary red
fill, and I'll set the text color to our
secondary cream. I'll also give it a
nice rounded look with a 50 pixel corner
radius.
Yep.
Now for the second button. So for the
second button, we'll use the cream color
fill. And I'll drop in our shopping cart
icon next to the text.
All right, I'll apply an auto layout
with 24 pixel spacing between the icon
and text
and align it with the rest of the
navigation.
And that's our navbar. There we go.
Clean, balanced, and ready.
So, let's just nudge our main heading
and supporting text a little higher just
to give it just give that layout more
breathing room.
And now I'll add just a a subtle spark
graphic just right here. Just a small
touch, but it adds a bit of personality
and motion to the uh hero section.
That's looking slick already. Cool.
All right.
All right. Now, the fun part. Let's
bring in our delicious hamburger. So,
I'm dragging it into the frame. And
since all layers are separated, we can
animate and style them individually.
So, first I'll go layer by layer and
apply a soft drop shadow to each one.
Now, this adds depth to make the burger
feel more real. Now, I'm not being too
precise with the values here. I'm just
tweaking it until it feels right.
And honestly, that's the beauty of it.
So just trust your eye and adjust until
it has the weight and the vibe that you
want.
[Music]
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Now, let's give the whole burger a bit
more spacing. I want it to feel open and
stacked, but not squished.
[Music]
I'll group all the layers just for a
second so that I can center align the
burger in the frame. Then ungroup them
again. It's important that the layers
stay ungrouped since we'll animate each
part individually later. So, next I'm
dropping in a light effect over the
burger. This is just um a subtle
highlight to make it glow a little bit
and feel more polished. So, I won't
create it from scratch here, but this
will be available to our Patreon members
in that source file.
And that soft shine makes a huge
difference. The burger already feels
more dynamic and alive, which is great.
Okay, the next thing we will create is a
scrollable bar. So, let's draw a
rectangle. This will be used for
scrolling and animating the design.
Let's do it with 8 pixels and a height
of 660
pixels.
We'll add a creamy color and reduce the
opacity to 14%.
Now we'll position the bar to the edge
of the screen. 8 pixels of distance
should be good.
Let's actually increase the opacity to
18% to make it more visible. All right.
And that's better.
So, we'll grab the existing bar, copy
and paste to create a smaller one. We'll
reduce the width to 4 and height to 218
pixels.
And we'll also make it round. For the
color, we'll select secondary cream.
We'll place that inside our main bar,
which we will also make round.
Fantastic.
And there it is. Our first screen is
done. If you made it this far,
seriously, that is a win. You built
something clean, custom, and full of
personality. But we're not stopping
here. And by the way, if you are
enjoying this tutorial so far and you're
thinking, "Wow, this looks amazing, but
how do I actually get good at making
things like this on my own?" Well, then
let me save you a ton of time and
frustration. Our UI UX playbook was made
for exactly this. For people who want to
learn how to build modern, clean UI
without second-guessing every layout,
every font, or spacing decision, over
20,000 designers, developers, and
marketers have downloaded it already,
and it's rated five stars because it
actually helps. We've received some some
really awesome great reviews on Trust
Pilot, so feel free to check them out
and see what our students are saying.
It's packed with top UX and UI design
tips from senior product designers, all
broken down in a way that is super easy
to apply. There's a link in the
description, so go ahead and grab it now
and uh you can keep following along with
this tutorial knowing that you have the
solid design foundation behind you ready
to go. So, let's get into the second
screen.
Now, truly, this is where the magic
happens. This is the way the the
animation actually works. And it's
actually super simple. When the same
element exists on both frames, but its
position or opacity changes, then Figma
animates between them. So, let's test
that.
So, on the first screen, we have our
title centered at 100% opacity. On the
second screen, I'll move it slightly and
reduce the opacity.
And that's it. When we prototype, Figma
will handle the animation between those
two states. But of course, we will still
need to set that animation.
[Music]
Next, we want to animate the scroll bar,
but also set the touch points that when
dragged on will trigger the animation.
So, I'll copy the scroll bar from screen
one, paste it into screen two.
Now, we'll create an artificial frame.
This will be the touch target. In the
prototype tab, I'll drag the connection
to the second screen. Then, set the
trigger to on drag. Animation type smart
animate. Easing set to ease in and ease
out. and duration to 800 milliseconds.
Next, let's prepare the horizontal
scroll effect. So, on the second screen,
I'll take the inner bar and shift it to
the center. That gives us space for
three horizontally scrolling sections.
So, what I'll do is I'll also add a
second artificial frame on the top half
of screen 2, just like before, and apply
the exact same prototype settings.
And let's preview that.
So, the titles sliding and fading. The
scroll bar moves smoothly. This is
actually looking real juicy. I like
this. Um, so now let's bring the
hamburger to life. So I'll start by
taking the bun layer and moving it up
the navigation bar.
Then grab the salad layer, place it
below the bun with a nice amount of
space.
Yeah, we'll fine tune that later.
[Music]
Repeat that for each layer. Tomato,
cheese, patty.
Spacing them vertically so that the
stack feels balanced.
And let's scale the entire burger up a
bit to make it pop.
Cool. So, I'll select all the layers,
increase the size just slightly, and
tweak the spacing just to make it feel
open and natural.
Now I'll move the whole burger stack to
be roughly centered vertically. Okay.
Let's preview that.
Perfect.
Now, now for the shine effect. So, just
a subtle highlight to make everything
feel more premium. I'll select the shine
layer on screen two. Move it slightly up
and to the side. Just enough to catch
the eye.
Preview that.
[Music]
Nice. Awesome. Yeah, just a little
movement, but it just adds so much for
that. Now, let's add a soft base under
the burger to anchor it visually.
I'll grab a circle, stretch it to 620
pixels wide by 62 pixels high, and place
it just below the burger.
Then I'll hit that to send it behind.
Set opacity to 13%.
And center align it.
Now I just realized that the burger is
not perfectly centered. So that's no
problem. What I'll do is I'll group all
the layers. align horizontally
and ungroup immediately. Now, that's
important because the animations won't
work with groups.
So, let's also add a slight shadow under
the burger to add some of the subtle
depth.
Cool.
Love that.
Now I'll copy that ellipse to the first
screen. Shrink it down.
Send it to the back.
Set its opacity to zero
and push it a bit lower using the arrow
keys.
Shrink it down.
Now, this way when we animate, it'll
fade and scale into view.
So, let's preview again.
Yeah, that's looking amazing. Cool.
Yeah, the shadow, the shine, the stack.
Cool. It all just works. It's great.
Last step for this section. Let's bring
it home. We are going to bring in some
decorative elements to really make this
layout shine. So, I'm grabbing our
tomato and basil graphics and I'm going
to be placing them around the burger.
And these little details add movement
and give the whole composition more
personality. I'll flip a few of them and
resize others. So, just to break that
symmetry and add some variation. Now,
that way the layout feels more natural
and dynamic. You can really get creative
here. Try different leaves. Try
different ingredients or whatever fits
your own theme.
Now, let's take it up a notch with a
blur effect. So, a few of these elements
will be blurred slightly just to create
some depth and make the burger feel like
it's popping off the screen. So once
everything looks good, I'll select the
elements and copy them back into the
first frame.
Now, here is where the animation magic
kicks in. So I'm going to rotate each of
these elements in the first frame and
reduce their opacity to zero. So that
way when we transition between screens,
they'll fade and rotate into place.
Subtle, but it's really effective.
So let's preview that.
Beautiful.
Awesome. Yeah, they're rotating in
cleanly. Uh but we're not done yet. So
now I'll just adjust their position in
the first frame, pushing them further
out from the center. So that extra
movement just gives them more travel
space during the animation, which makes
the entrance feel more natural and
impactful
and let's preview again.
Wow, that adds that adds so much depth
and energy. So the whole scene feels
really alive right now. So, let's let's
now highlight some of the premium
qualities of this burger. What we're
going to do is create ingredient
highlight pills. They're little floating
callouts to that actually explain what
makes this burger so special.
The first one, organic sesame seed bun.
Now, that tells our users this isn't
just any bun. It's made from healthy
organic ingredients. I'll wrap the text
in an auto layout and give the pill a
fully rounded shape. Setting the corner
radius to 55 pixels.
For the fill, I'll start with our light
cream color, but convert it to a linear
ingredient. Sorry, linear gradient to
give it uh depth.
And I'll lower the opacity
to 16% so that it's visible but soft.
Then I'll adjust the gradient direction
until it feels right.
[Music]
Next, I'll add uh just a soft stroke,
also using a gradient, and play with the
opacity until it blends just right.
And final touch, I'll add padding 16
pixels on all sides.
Now I'll bring in our bun icon. I'm
going to place it in the pill and set
its color to our light orange.
I'll also change the pill text color to
secondary cream to keep it consistent.
Great. Awesome. Now I will duplicate
this pill to create a second one.
[Music]
So for the highlights, I'll change the
font style to body large medium just to
make it slightly bigger. Then I'll
repeat the same process for a third
highlight.
and and
all right. Now that we've got all three,
I'll wrap them in auto layout and copy
the group on the right side of the
burger.
We'll make sure everything is center
aligned on both sides.
[Music]
For the middle pill, we need to set it
to hug content and apply the same
setting to the parent auto layout as
well.
Once all the pills are placed and
aligned, then I'll check the positioning
to make sure both sides are balanced.
Then I'll select all the pills, copy
them over to the first frame, and send
them to the back by pressing this a few
times.
I'll make them smaller just to give them
some some motion in the transition.
[Music]
I'll group them quickly, align them to
center, and then ungroup right after.
So, finally, I'll reduce their opacity
to zero in the first screen so that they
fade in during the animation.
All right, and let's preview what we've
got so far.
All right, everything's working
beautifully. The highlight pills fade
and scale in. That's great. Gives the
whole burger a sense of of quality. So,
this is the kind of detail that makes
the design feel really premium. All
right. Now, let's set up the final
screen.
So, first we'll fold the hamburger
layers back to the original stacked
position. Then shift the whole burger
toward the corner to make space for
content.
I'll move the ingredient highlights too.
shrink them down and drop the opacity to
0% so that they'll so that they'll
animate out cleanly.
Now, let's set up the touch point for
dragging. On the second screen here,
I'll create a drag area that will
trigger the transition to screen three.
[Music]
In the prototype tab, I'll connect it to
the third screen using the same
animation settings. Smart animate, ease
in and out, 800 milliseconds. And on the
third screen, I'll set the arrow I'll
set the back arrow to link back to the
second. Again, keeping the same
animation style.
Let's drop the scroll bar in. I'll move
it to the bottom of the main bar so that
it fits the layout.
Quick preview.
A, that looks smooth.
And next up, let's animate the floating
veggies.
I'll rotate them slightly, move them
closer to the screen edges.
and drop their opacity to 0% in the
screen.
Preview again.
Perfect. Smooth, clean, and adds just
just the right amount of movement on
that. That's great. And now let's add
the final screen content. I'll start
with the title using our large text
style. Setting the width to
482 pixels.
123% to keep it neat.
We'll go with the secondary cream color
for that. Below that, I'll drop in some
catchy supporting copy.
and then show off the reviews.
I'll add five stars using a new color.
Let's call it vivid orange. Something
that really just pops against the
background.
Heat. Heat.
and then I'll drop in the rating score
and number of reviews right next to it.
Oops.
And
Now let's add our two call to action
buttons, one for add to basket and one
for order now.
[Music]
All
right, I'll use auto layout to align and
space everything properly so that it
feels really balanced.
Down.
Hey.
And let next let's bring in the pricing
using a larger font style to make it
stand out.
And below that, the calorie count, of
course, just to give the user a sense of
what they're ordering.
And I'll wrap the whole info block in
some extra spacing
and add a soft stroke to frame the
section without making it too heavy.
[Music]
last alignment check and everything
should be nicely centered.
Awesome.
Now I'll copy this entire content box to
the second screen, send it to the back,
make it smaller, and reduce its opacity
to 0%. So that way it fades in
beautifully during the final transition.
[Music]
One more detail. I will change the
stroke color from light gray to dark
gray for just a bit more contrast.
Quick preview.
Ah, that looks smooth.
And we'll reposition the light so that
it sits directly above the burger,
giving that nice balanced glow.
All right, let's preview the full
experience from start to finish.
Wow,
this is looking absolutely amazing.
Yes. Awesome. Cool. Great job everyone
who has made it so far. This tutorial uh
took a lot of work. So if you enjoyed it
then support us on Patreon. grab the
source files and unlock even more
behindthe-scenes content. And again, I
would love to see what you create. So,
if you post your version, then tag us
because seriously, it means the world.
Drop some love in the comments and let
me know what you'd like to see next.
Thanks so much for watching and we'll
see you in the next one. Thanks, guys.